hey guys welcome back to reality check
so another Steam sale has come and gone
over the last month to the mix sounds of
PC gamers rejoicing and their wallets
grueling but what if you're a strict
console gamer and have never waded into
a Steam sale what is it all about
well sweat not to help you understand
Lucy here gained sports brand new video
producer is gonna help me simulate the
experience so lysse here is all of my
money thank you alright
what are you doing what what is that you
do realize I'm one I'm gonna play like
two or three of these right I said so so
why do we do it what is about the Steam
sale that makes people so willing to
part with so much cash
[Music]
now at this point I should clarify that
I think steam is pretty great it's super
convenient downloading games is easy and
unlike some other online stores it
doesn't rip you off for the pleasure of
not having physical media however if you
put on your psychology hat it does seem
that some of the features and practices
used in the sale are very well-suited
for exploiting our innate human brain
[Music]
[Applause]
sales in general are obviously great at
getting people to part with cash and a
significant part of this is our tendency
to get caught up in the arousal and
excitement of the event and this in turn
inhibits clear thinking and judgment
steam sales also do a bunch of the
classic tricks learned by retailers over
the years tricks like displaying
discounts as percentages as opposed to
absolute amounts take this example from
the most recent steam summer sale you
can get your hands on far cry 3 for 75%
off down to just 3 pounds and 75 pence a
great deal no doubt but 75% off
certainly sounds better than save 11
pounds 25 pence doesn't it instantly
this general rule reverses when you
start dealing with large amounts of
money for example for a $2,000 computer
save $500 sounds much more compelling
than just 25% off
perhaps the smartest thing steam sales
do is create this idea of artificial
scarcity 24-hour daily deals and even
more put in eight-hour flash sales both
give you a limited time to get the
benefit and remember once those deals
are gone they're gone
so why does this make us more willing to
part with our cash well first off
psychological study has repeatedly shown
that we value things more highly when we
think they are rare scarcity straight-up
enhances desirability being estimating
the value of artwork wine or even
cookies meaning people repeatedly assign
higher value to rarer objects another
reason why these time limiting deals can
seem so compelling is down to something
called loss aversion this is our natural
human tendency to value avoiding a loss
much more highly than potentially
getting it gained imagine losing 20
pounds on the street say our experiments
have shown that it's likely you would
need to find as much as 30 or even 40
pounds at a later date to make up for
the pain of that initial loss all this
boils down to our brains truly hating to
lose out on a good deal so we'd rather
just purchase that game in the 8 hour
flash sale rather than risk feeling the
pain of missing out steam also do a
great job of exploiting gamification now
this is essentially using elements from
games to encourage people to participate
steam trading cards are a great example
these are cards which you earn and
unlock just by playing games on Steam
these can then be crafted into badges
for your profile which are new rewards
and of course kudos from your Steam
friends during a sale however steam
introduces new cards which can be earned
in a number of ways but also through
making game purchases or even buying the
cards directly
they can also be crafted into badges too
which makes for a tempting cherry on top
reason for making that purchase you were
undecided on this whole process exploits
what is known as the endowed Progress
effect now this is when if someone feels
they're making progress towards a goal
they're more likely to be committed to
then finishing that goal the gotta catch
them all effect if you will
as Jamie Madigan points out in his
excellent article the psychology behind
steam summer sale just showing that
you've begun progress towards the goal
is enough to create some mental
ancien over not having yet reached it
and some people are likely to toss in
just one more cheap game to get them
over that hump
in the most recent steam summer sale
valve brought in something called the
steam summer adventure and in doing so
that something very tricky indeed for
the first time they made people join
teams everyone who participated in the
sale was randomly assigned a team blue
pink green purple or red now various
actions such as crafting badges would
earn your team points then at the end of
each day the team with the most points
would win and some members of that team
who had contributed would win prizes
sounds fair enough
the thing is though this exploits our
natural tendency towards belonging to
groups the idea of in groups and air
groups psychology research has
demonstrated time and time again that
when people are put into teams they
naturally behave positively to those in
their team and negatively towards others
even when assigned to a team at random
so if your team red naturally you're
gonna want team red to win and so you
may be more inclined to collect more
cards craft more badges and earn more
points very clever steam very clever but
what other clever things could steam do
in the future to further exploit our
silly brains well in addition to being
our newest video producer Lucy also has
a psychology degree so Lizzie you want
to field this one okay well what about
the idea of reciprocity which is the
fancy psychology way of saying that we
feel the need to return a favor in kind
so what kind of favor could steam do for
us well what about a free game we might
not even play it but the fact that it's
there might push us into wanting to
repay the favor by buying something in
the sale or what if a game you're kind
of interested in doesn't have a demo you
don't want to pay money in case you
don't like it so what a steam that you
play through it for a limited amount of
time they're doing you a favor so you
might be more inclined to cough up when
that timer runs out in fact studies have
shown that we do this with each other in
response to acts of human kindness often
repaying more than the initial gesture
is worth so if we do this in real life
with other people then why not with our
favorite digital distribution services
as well
okay we'll make sure you let us know
what you thought of this week's episode
in the comments box down below or by
reaching out to me and Lisi directly
over Twitter I'm at cam freeze rope and
she's at Lucy James games oh and also a
huge thank you to Jamie Madigan this
week for his amazing article on the
psychology of the steam summer sale for
more and all this stuff make sure you go
and read that and in fact check out his
whole website on the psychology of video
games it's really is fantastic okay come
back next week though for more reality
check I'll see you then
[Music]